it really bothers me the most about the
Batman villain mr. freeze before he went
all sub-zero he was a doctor named
Victor freeze so why on earth would he
choose the name mr. freeze why but
you're not really hiding your identity
all that well by changing the spelling
of your last name and - why did you go
down in title from doctor - mr. at least
take credit for all that dissertation
research you did
[Music]
hello Internet welcome to film theory
where what's cooler than being cool
science I also would have accepted ice
cold now through loyal theorists we'll
remember that last year I was invited by
Bill and Melinda Gates to make a video
inspired by their annual letter a yearly
tradition of theirs meant to outline an
underrepresented global crisis that
needs to be addressed their letters job
is to broaden awareness of the problem
and call all of us to do our part in
making the world a better healthier
place for everyone last year it was a
letter about superpowers for good so I
talked about Deadpool obviously this
year's letter is focused on providing
solutions for global health issues
related to women and children and so I
wanted to see my video around Batman
seriously so that might seem like an odd
logical leave but hear me out here first
the people who are on the front lines
doing work in fields like scientific
research funding and on-the-ground
treatment are the closest things this
world has to superheroes literally going
out to save lives every day just like
Batman and it's worth noting that these
people aren't even billionaire Playboy's
except I guess for Bill Gates himself
probably qualifies just like Batman
these people are making a difference
since 1990 the lives of a hundred and
twenty two million children have been
saved by the efforts of these everyday
heroes and it's not just for children
either since 2010 HIV infections are
down by five percent back then only 7.5
million people were getting treated now
it's over 17 million deaths from malaria
are down a whopping 29% in that same
amount of time the work of these
real-life superheroes is making a
difference and our support in whatever
way from monetarily to donating our time
to just spreading awareness is taking
down diseases and quite literally
changing lives and making the world a
better place but seriously what does any
of this have to do with Batman well old
Willy Gates has challenged me to make a
video on the subject of finding
treatments for some of the world's most
aggressive and incurable diseases got me
thinking about Mr Freeze now if there's
one villain that needs to be rebooted
it's this guy and no I'm not just saying
it because of arnold schwarzenegger
endless stream of terrible ice puns from
Batman and Robin who
all right everyone chill always went to
write your pipe okay well so maybe a
little bit because of that but more so
because Mr Freeze is really an antihero
he's a scientist whose wife contracts a
rare fatal disease called MacGregor's
syndrome so he cryogenically freeze it
there to keep her from dying and will
now do absolutely anything to find a
cure I gotta be honest I feel for the
guy so today let's help him out and get
to the bottom of the McGregor Syndrome
mystery it isn't a real disease but can
we find a real-world version of McGregor
syndrome to see if this mad scientists
plan forward or if the chances of saving
his wife are an absolute zero
I can make cold puns to Arnie and I
should alas just because I can doesn't
mean that I should so to start what does
the batman universe tell us and show us
about McGregor syndrome the first time
it's alluded to is in an episode of
batman the animated series from 1992
with that epic music and incredible art
style which explains how Victor fries
turns evil when he attempts to research
a cure for his wife Nora's disease and
it's forcibly stopped the disease itself
isn't named McGregor syndrome until a
few years later in the film Batman and
Robin my vines have a crush on you oh oh
god please know that film also gives us
our first clues as to the nature of the
illness when Batman and Robin inspect
Nora's cryo tube you can clearly see
that it has four stages later on in the
movie we see that Mr Freeze has found
the cure for the first stage and it's
some sort of weird glowing Gatorade and
that honestly about it because we never
seen Nora suffering from the disease at
all she's frozen and lifeless throughout
movie looks like George Clooney's
performance hey-oh shots fired Babu
that's my makeshift air horn instead
some of our best Clues come not from the
movies or animated series but from
season two of Gotham in which we see
Victor fries yeah for some reason they
changed his name so now it's pronounced
like french fries much better for hiding
your identity there Mick actively
working on the cure for a very sick but
also very alive Nora in these episodes
we see her coffin blood have difficulty
breathing and generally seem to be
pretty darn fray
still not a whole lot to go off of but
when most others would walk away that's
when I get really intense in the
direct-to-video movie Batman and mr.
freeze sub-zero freeze learns that
Barbara Gordon has the exact same rare
blood type as Nora so to save his wife
he tries to kidnap Barbara so he can
perform a fatal organ transplant and
digging even deeper across the DC
Universe we find that Nora isn't the
only one suffering from the disease in
the CW series the flash
Francine West reveals that she also has
McGregor syndrome and that it's common
among ex drug addicts
that's a huge clue that I'm still not
done the biggest hint of all comes from
arrow where William tockman aka the
clock king is determined to have
McGregor syndrome which is described in
the episode as the greatest engine the
genetic defect that creates fluid
buildup in the lungs which leads to
oxygen deprivation and filter system
organ failure
so to recap its genetic attacks the
lungs has four stages is treated with
glowing and hit other organs can
potentially be solved with a transplant
that is more common among drug addicts
that's a lot of information so maybe
through the process of elimination we'll
be able to get to the bottom of Nora's
disease dilemma and spoiler alert it's
not lupus don't worry dr. house I
checked so let's start with the obvious
solution lung cancer in Batman and Robin
the main conflict of the movie is that
Nora is in an advanced stage of
MacGregor's syndrome whereas later on in
the movie we learned that everyone's
favorite Butler Alfred except you mr.
Beauregard you're the best
has just been diagnosed with stage 1 now
as many people know cancer progresses in
four stages from the first where the
cancer is small and contained only in
the location of the tumor to stage 4 in
which the cancer has spread to many
tissues in the body making it much more
likely to be fatal combine this fact
with the blood that Nora coughs up and
it's not too hard to make a strong case
for lung cancer but that is where the
similarities stop rarely this theorist
what was the cure being liquidus that
glow sway that's just a reference to the
radiation used during chemotherapy then
what about the organ transplant from Sub
Zero I guess that would just be her
getting a new lung to replace the one
that's too damaged from the
sir this is looking a lot more
open-and-shut than I expected uh what
about that obscure moment from the flash
cancer is it more likely to be an
ex-drug addict though wrong
actually some lung cancer is more likely
in drug addicts former drug addicts are
statistically more likely to be addicted
to cigarettes between 80 and 95 percent
of alcoholics are found to smoke
cigarettes and a study found that those
undergoing treatment for heroin
addiction smoked cigarettes a staggering
97% of the time and yeah even Alfred two
early portrayals of the character showed
him smoking a pipe so him being in stage
one actually makes a lot of sense you
know come to think of it that stuff from
arrow fit to genetics multi-organ
failure lungs filled with liquid all of
it comes with advanced stages of lung
cancer you know come to think of it we
can also rule out other deadly lung
diseases like pertussis and tuberculosis
because they're highly contagious when
Batman and Robin learned that Alfred has
MacGregor syndrome don't exactly put him
into quarantine or start wearing
surgical masks they're still in full
contact with him the whole time just as
Victor's in contact with Nora throughout
the Gotham episode thinking of those
gossip episodes by the way when Victor
comes home to find Nora coughing up
blood he keeps asking about a medication
called for Mitter all later freezing a
drugstore to harvest the entire supply
of the drugs now for mineral doesn't
exist but there is a suspiciously
similar sounding drug on the market
called promoter all four motor oil is a
long-acting bronchodilator that clears a
person's airway and makes it easier for
them to breathe so uh huh I guess it's
lung cancer I expected it to be a bit
tougher than that I mean I guess you
could say that lung cancer isn't rare
but there are plenty of weird unique
strains of cancer out there so damn so
we would pull some really obscure rare
lung thing had this whole episode
planned eliminating things one at a time
building to the big final twist but
uh-huh not really used to this my seven
paragraph structure is just thrown out
that we know I don't know I guess I
could just end the episode now but hey
that's no wait what's interesting about
mr. Freeze's situation isn't the disease
itself it's the cure you see this woman
nor freeze tube girl yeah her mr. freeze
froze her to stall for time until he
discovered a cure except he
is the thing this girl right here in the
tube she's already cured that person
that you're seeing suspended in this
tube right now in that present moment
she is cancer-free McGregor syndrome
free no joke mr. freeze has cured her
and here's how it's a treatment called
cryosurgery and it literally means
curing cancer by freezing the cancer
cells directly specialized surgeons use
super targeted cold raised in a
cryoprobe just think Mr Freeze is cold
ray just micro-sized and freeze the
cancer cells to death I mean think about
it cancer is just a bunch of
out-of-control cells and freezing them
does basically the same thing that does
to that bunch of lettuce that
accidentally got frozen in your fridge
when it solves its limp and dead because
all the cells have broken down the same
thing happens to the cells in your body
after they've been frozen with liquid
nitrogen so Mr Freeze in deep chilling
Nora has actually killed all the cancer
cells in her body she's officially cured
haha except there's a catch
of course doctors performing cryosurgery
target the cells are looking to kill
with these icy cold blasts by using very
tiny cryoprobe mr. freeze just in case
Nora and ice like her whole body
according to those episodes of Gaza mr.
waffle fries is using liquid helium to
freeze his life and liquid helium is
like the coldest of cold substances that
humanity can create at a temperature of
minus 452 degrees Fahrenheit for
comparison the liquid nitrogen doctors
use a balmy negative 320 degrees
Fahrenheit a full hundred and thirty
degrees hotter if you can consider
hotter and colder when you're talking
about negative hundreds of degrees so
yeah he not only killed all the cancer
cells he also killed all Noora cells in
the process and if you think curing
cancer is hard hearing I just made my
wife into a human fudge stick hole is
way harder when asked about it biology
professor Michael Hendrix at McGill
University stated that's a technology
required to bring someone back from a
completely frozen State quote does not
yet exist even in principle it's also
something we've covered here on games
here he can't just freeze people and
bring them
back to life so the worst part here that
Mr Freeze had the cure or at least a
pretty solid treatment the entire time
if he had been a bit more precise with
that freezing gun of his he could have
helped treat Nora's lung cancer himself
but it's AC solution has actually doomed
his wife to death man
irony is cold but hey that's just a
theory a film theory and before I wrap
things up one final big thank you to
Bill and Melinda Gates for not only
asking me to once again join their
campaign for spreading awareness of
global health issues but for the good
work that they're doing in the world
through things like their annual letter
get a easy to sit on your throne of 84
billion dollars and just I don't know do
whatever things super-rich people do
live in a gold-plated house or fly in
your gold-plated plane or whatever else
you might want a gold plate since that's
what I assume rich people do all the
time but actually going out and doing
something positive for the world is just
awesome so before you leave this video
to watch whatever let's play is on next
or fail clip compilation that may be
waiting in your playlist do the world a
favor by clicking the link in the
description to read the gates annual
letter if nothing else that'll get you
to think about the challenges people in
less fortunate parts of the world have
to live through so educate yourself and
be a force for good by clicking that
link because if I can get really real
here for a second
true success in life isn't defined by
how much you earn but rather by how you
leave the world a slightly better place
than when you first enter it thanks guys
and I'll see you all next week